[Musique]
je sais pas trop papa on dirait que tu
vis dans une maison pleine de gosse mais
c'est très joli
c'est festif tu t'es organiser une mini
parade de noël
[Musique]
à ce qu'il paraît t puis dans le film
sans vie dans un monde monstrueuse
occupy tout ça pour quoi
une maison plus grande alors tu as des
projets d'avenir bah je fais aussi un
peu de boulot pour une chose la maladie
les maladies une association dans le
domaine du cancer
c'est pareil non de divorcer vous avez
des enfants
oui oui j'en ai mais est ce que tu
cherches un boulot - oui j'en ai trouvé
un oui oui je fais les livraisons de
pinard habitent ici j'aurais cru que ça
c'était ton genre c'est quoi ton temps à
toi chauffeur livreur
on dirait bien je crois qu'il ait perdu
aux colères hausse il me fait penser au
type qui est assis en face de fourche
j'en ai du pot qui tu as pris ta lâcher
ton ou l'autre la mort j'ai pris des
décisions mais tu peux pas débarquer
comme ça non tu es bourré il a récupéré
quelques petites affaires faut que vous
vous détendez lui un gros de gauche
disent qu moi tu te fous de ma gueule
d'un goût de fleurs mais qu'est-ce qui
va pas chez toi
bordel je t'en conjure vas-y casse toi
quand je t'ai vu à la fenêtre il ya deux
secondes j'ai cru que c'était lui j'ai
quelques questions à se poser
preston n'a rien fait dans cette
histoire j'ai rien dit à personne je
sais pas comment ils l'ont su je suis
désolé où es tu nous a pas contacté je
te prie ce book un livre érotique volée
à la bibliothèque de ben non je suis
désolé que tu es à perd aussi décevant
ok
dans le temps j'imaginais coeur ma vie a
été un genre de toiles immenses plus on
voulait partir de soi des fils raccorder
à d'autres toiles tout ça faisait de
nous un personnage important résultat si
on disparaît alors toute personne qui
faisait partie de notre vie se mettent à
tisser des villes avec quelqu'un d'autre
doit alors on n'est plus là et la toile
commencent à se reformer autour de nos
proches et tout le monde avance très
bien sûr nous
[Musique]